[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend das saarland hat
den wechsel gewählt und zwar mit
ausrufezeichen da geht es mal nicht um
prozentpunkte hinter dem komma es gibt
die ganz großen balken mit gewinnen und
mit verlusten die spd bislang der
kleinere partner in einer großen
koalition hat jetzt die cdu weit hinter
sich gelassen und kann künftig sogar
allein regieren mit absoluter mehrheit
die bisherige wirtschaftsministerin anke
rehlinger wird neue ministerpräsidentin
in saarbrücken bevor wir mit ihr reden
und da mal genauer drauf gucken hat
matthias fornoff jetzt ein ergebnis und
da sollte ich vielleicht auch ein
bisschen rübergehen bisschen näher
hierhin kommen matthias wie sieht es
denn aus künftig zum heute journal gibt
es das vorläufige amtliche endergebnis
mit vielen verschiebungen im
kräfteverhältnis der parteien und das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an die cdu
kommt auf 28,5 prozent mit starken
verlusten die spd wird stärkste partei
43,5 mit noch stärkeren zu gewinnen die
linke stürzt ab auf 2,6 prozent ist
nicht mehr im landtag vertreten
mit sehr großen verlusten die afg bei
5,7 leichte verluste aber weiter im
landtag und jetzt kommen wir zu den
grünen da haben wir mal die zweite zahl
hinter dem komma noch mit genannt 4,99
die wirklichkeit ist noch dramatischer
es sind 4,9 95 prozent der stimmen viel
knapper kann man an der fünf prozent
hürde nicht scheitern und nach auskunft
des landeswahlleiters ging es dabei um
23 stimmen um das aber auch noch dazu zu
sagen selbst wenn sie diese 23 stimmen
oder mehr geholt hätten die spd hätte
trotzdem die absolute mehrheit die fdp
habe immer gesagt 4,8 prozent ist etwas
deutlicher nicht drin und die anderen
kommen auf einen hohen wert von zehn
prozent das sind zwölf kleine und
kleinstparteien die stärkste ist die
tierschutzpartei mit 2,3 prozent und
jetzt gucken wir mal auf die
sitzverteilung
die anzahl der sitze 51 im saarbrücker
landtag die stärkste fraktion wird die
spd mit 29 sitzen die cdu kommt auf 19
sitze und die afg auf drei grüne und fdp
gerade gesehen nicht drin und das heißt
dass die absolute mehrheit bei der spd
liegt wir schauen noch kurz auf die
wahlbeteiligung die ist etwas gesunken
nicht nur etwas ist deutlich gesunken
von 69,7 prozent vor fünf jahren auf
jetzt 61,4 prozent matthias also ein
landtag ein künftiger in saarbrücken mit
ganzen drei parteien noch drin gucken
mal ein bisschen hinter dieses
wahlergebnis mit dem amtsbonus für einen
ministerpräsidenten sah sie am aus im
saarland von wo kommen sie denn her die
wähler der spd ja in der tat den
amtsbonus gab es de facto nicht die
herausforderung anke rehlinger war ja
schon zehn jahre im geschäft als vize
regierungschefin sie hatte vielleicht
eher er diesen amtsbonus und jetzt
schauen wir mal woher kamen die wähler
der spd wer heute spd gewählt hat der
hat vor fünf jahren auch schon spd
gewählt das sind ungefähr das sind
schätzwerte
105000 cdu vor fünf jahren gewählt das
sind 45.000 linke 25.000 andere 15.000
und nichtwähler 20.000 wir sehen also
sehr deutlich die spd gewinnt am
stärksten vor den anderen parteien bei
der cdu und da ganz besonders bei den
über 60-jährigen da sehen wir eine
wähler struktur bei der spd die wir
normalerweise so er bei der cdu sehen
matthias ganz herzlichen dank nach
saarbrücken dann schauen wir doch jetzt
auf die bilder dieses denkwürdigen
abends im saarland mit verena kerth und
dominik löschmeister
sie wirkt als könne sie es gar nicht
fassen wenige minuten nach der ersten
hochrechnung wendet sich anke rehlinger
an ihrer partei
das saarland hat roth gewählt die saar
spd hat die wahl gewonnen und nach
23 jahren sind wir wieder stärkste kraft
als sozialdemokratie an der saar
glück und erleichterungen bei den
genossen ich bin total überwältigt ich
hatte damit gerechnet
das ist einfach überwältigend ich bin
komplett gelöscht die spd an der saar
ist unweigerlich mit ihm verknüpft oskar
lafontaine von 1985 bis 98 war er
ministerpräsident dreimal hintereinander
gewählt mit absoluter mehrheit er hat
die partei groß gemacht und später auch
ein bisschen kleiner als er die linke
gründeten aber viele stammwähler mit die
fehlten dann der spd es folgten 23
schwierige jahre für die partei das
saarland feste cdu hans peter müller
dann annegret kramp karrenbauer heiko
maas scheiterte drei mal bei einer
landtagswahl und auch anke rehlinger
hatte es 2017 schon einmal versucht
damals verlor
heute trauert die cdu und er ist der
verlierer tobias hans übernimmt die
verantwortung für seine niederlage
des wahlergebnisses mit meiner person
verbunden als spitzenkandidat und
deswegen werde ich auch persönliche
konsequenzen mit dem vorstand mit der
fraktion am morgigen tag beraten gewählt
von den saarländerinnen und saarländern
wurde er nie sein amt hatte er geerbt
als kramp karrenbauer nach berlin ging
sie haben halt nicht gelungen diesen
ministerpräsidenten bonus so
auszuspielen das liegt vielleicht zum
einen daran dass eben er bisher nicht
mit dem rückenwind eines wahlsieges
agieren konnte zum zweiten aber eben an
der stärke der gegenkandidatin die
grünen haben sich früh gefreut
vielleicht zu früh die afd ist drin
schlechter als erwartet die fdp verpasst
wohl den einzug in den landtag die
linken im politischen nichts zug wird
oskar lafontaine aus der partei
ausgetreten auch im wahlkampf nicht
daran es ist uns natürlich nicht
gelungen auch das ist klar die
differenzen die auseinandersetzungen so
beizulegen um die wählerinnen und wähler
zu überzeugen
die spd feiert und mit ihr anke
rehlinger nach mehr als zwei jahrzehnten
wird es an der saar einen wechsel geben
und sogar eine absolute mehrheit der spd
wie damals beim letzten mal
anke rehlinger wird also neue
ministerpräsidentin in saarbrücken hier
ist sie bei uns guten namen vorgänger
einen schönen guten abend und glückauf
außer brücken glückauf nach saarbrücken
nach seit einer halben stunde ist jetzt
klar sie haben auch die absolute
mehrheit jetzt wirkten sie den ganzen
abend über doch so ein bisschen so als
hätten sie davor vielleicht auch ein
bisschen bammel wäre ihnen am ende eine
koalition lieber gewesen
beide alternativen haben vor und
nachteile
es scheint jetzt sozusagen das ist einen
klaren hinweis darauf gibt dass die
absolute mehrheit die form ist mit der
wir die nächsten jahre diese zukunft des
landes gestalten wir haben uns viel
vorgenommen und das wollen wir jetzt
auch umsetzen wenn die bisherige
wirtschaftsministerin den amtsbonus in
einen wahlsieg ummünzen kann aber der
bisherige ministerpräsident abgestraft
wird was heißt denn das jetzt für die
künftige politik im saarland bleibt sie
im grunde so wie sie war oder wird sie
sich grundlegend ändern
naja man muss vielleicht nicht alles
anders machen und man muss an der stelle
sicherlich auch sagen dass wir ja seit
zehn jahren regiert haben mit regiert
haben und auch gemeinsam viele erfolge
organisiert haben aber vielleicht an der
einen oder anderen stelle doch etwas
besser machen ich habe gesagt ich würde
gerne das thema arbeitsplätze und den
strukturwandel aus der staatskanzlei
heraus noch mehr koordinieren als mir
das als wirtschaftsministerin in den
letzten jahren möglich war auch die
vernetzung in berlin suchen und nutzen
zum wohle unseres landes unser
bundesland hat grosse aufgaben im
strukturwandel vor sich wir wollen
daraus neue kraft und neue stärke und
auch ein neues selbstbewusstsein
entwickeln da wird uns nichts geschenkt
werden insofern geht es in den nächsten
jahren vor allem ums machen und
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger auch ums
reden große aufgabe haben sie vor sich
im strukturwandel haben sie gerade
gesagt das stimmt einer von vier jobs im
saarland hängt aktuell direkt oder
indirekt an der automobilindustrie heißt
das ihr job frau rehlinger hängt jetzt
in zukunft vor allem daran diese jobs in
eine e auto zukunft zu überführen
die frage wie wir wirtschaftspolitisch
und strukturpolitisch aufgestellt sein
werden kann man nicht nur mit einer
antwort hier beantworten sondern dazu
braucht es mehrere ansätze wir wollen
dass das auto der zukunft hier im
saarland gebaut wird es gibt
unterschiedliche antriebstechnologien
wir brauchen eine starke brücke über den
hybrid aber wir wollen natürlich auch
den star der zukunft hier bauen genauso
wie wir das thema it-sicherheit
tourismus nach vorne bringen wollen denn
insgesamt müssen wir schlicht und
ergreifend etwas breiter aufgestellt
sein damit wir eben nicht immer auch an
den fragen von einer branche hängen im
wohl und dem weg aus dem saarland kamen
in der vergangenheit häufiger schon
überproportional viel politik trends und
auch politik personal für die
bundespolitik am ende dann auch was sagt
uns diese wahl jetzt für berlin
sie sagt vor allem für die
saarländerinnen und saarländer der sich
alle möglichkeiten nutzen werde in
berlin um das beste für unser land auch
rauszuholen und es sagt eben auch dass
die saar-spd gut vernetzt und gut
unterstützt worden ist auch durch das
willy brandt haus durch alle die dort
mitgeholfen haben auch in der
bundesregierung eben mit guter politik
als rückenwind allen voran olaf scholz
mit sehr klaren sehr umsichtigen
entscheidungen in schwierigen zeiten das
hat neben dem guten profil das wir als
spd entwickelt haben und der eigenen
stärke die wir haben sehr geholfen dafür
bin ich auch sehr dankbar und ich hoffe
dass es den kolleginnen und kollegen in
schleswig holstein in
nordrhein-westfalen und einem starken
ministerpräsidenten stephan weil in
niedersachsen genauso helfen wird zum
schluss kurz noch was ganz anderes sie
halten die saarländischen landesrekorde
im kugelstoßen aktuell und ich glaube
auch im diskuswerfen geht das auch als
ministerpräsidentin
na ja ich würde mich ehrlich gesagt
eigentlich freuen wenn unsere
talentförderung dazu führt dass mich
jemand an dieser stelle ablöst als
ministerpräsidentin würde ich gerne
länger im amt bleiben die rekorde würde
ich gerne an ein talent abgeben
vielleicht schaffen wir es auch über
gute talentförderung das auch noch
hinzubekommen das saarland ist nicht nur
industrieland sohn ist nicht nur ein
wichtiger wirtschaftsstandort sondern es
ist eben auch ein sportland und da wären
wir mal sehen was wir in den nächsten
jahren noch hinbekommen anke rehlinger
herzlichen dank für das gespräch nach
saarbrücken
herzlichen dank
das saarland mag klein sein und manchmal
belächelt werden aber von der sa sind
schon gewaltige trends herbst grad schon
gesagt ausgegangen die dann ziemlich
schnell auch berlin in atem hielten ich
sag nur oskar lafontaine aber auch nach
der letzten wahl dort 2017 war das so
damals begann für die spd eine serie von
niederlagen bis hin zur vergangenen
bundestagswahl
was heißt der wahlausgang diesmal also
für die cdu im bund weniger
an einer frage kommt die cdu nicht
vorbei wer ist schuld an der misere
die in berlin oder air hier hatten sie
das gefühl genügend über unterstützung
zu haben gerade auch von der bundes
partei im saarland schauen sie jetzt in
so einer situation
nach anderen zu schauen und zu teilen
das ist nicht mein stil das war es nie
was ich aber erlebt habe ist dass aus
dem gesamten bundesgebiet über die phase
des wahlkampfs menschen gekommen sind
aus der partei eine tierärztin aus dem
brandenburgischen junge menschen aus
allen bundesländern das ist ein
schienbein tritt gegen die cdu spitze
die zuletzt anfang märz mal im saarland
gesehen wurde parteichef märz bieber in
berlin sein generalsekretär auch mit der
niederlage will man hier nichts zu tun
haben
gewinnen zusammen und wir verlieren
zusammen insofern gehen wir auch
gemeinsam jetzt
mit diesem wahlergebnis um aber
deutliches gewesen es ging um
saarländische themen in diesem wahlkampf
das ist der versuch möglichst viel
abstand zum verlierer zu schaffen für
märz und für die nächsten landtagswahlen
damit die ausgangsposition gegenüber der
spd nicht noch schlechter wird dort
herrscht kontrolliert grosse freude für
uns als spd auf bundesebene ist das ein
besonderer tag weil wir künftig die
hälfte aller ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsident in deutschland stellen
werden acht von 16 4 übrigens vier sind
davon frauen alle vier sind
sozialdemokraten und auch das zeigt wir
sind die moderne volkspartei die die
richtigen perspektiven auf das ganze
land hat andere müssen zittern weniger
die afg als fdp und grüne wir drücken
die daumen dass die jetzt zuletzt
positive prognose und die positive
hochrechnung dass das am ende auch das
ergebnis des abends sein wird unsere
freundinnen und freunde an der saar
hätten es wahrlich nach zehn jahren ab
hofer das sieht sehr gut aus dass es
wieder eine starke stimme gibt für
klimaschutz im landtag im saarland und
vor allem dass wir endlich wieder in
allen landtagen im bund überall
vertreten sind nirgends dass die
stimmung so im keller wie hier es bleibt
nur ein erkenntnisgewinn zerstrittene
parteien werden nicht gewählt
noch dazu
in einer zeit in der leute nach
sicherheit nach antworten suchen es war
ja nur eine landtagswahl sagen alle was
für eine landtagswahl sagt man bei der
spd
und die wahl an der saar kommentiert
jetzt zdf chefredakteur peter frey
das saarland ist das gallische dorf
unter den deutschen bundesländern am
rand gelegen französisch angehaucht
eigen und liebenswert rund
750.000 wählerinnen und wähler das
kleinste landesparlament aufstieg und
fall liegen dort heute nah beieinander
der triumph der anke rehlinger ist auch
der absturz des tobias hans im saarland
haben sich nach 22 jahren cdu-herrschaft
die verhältnisse umgedreht die
spd-spitzenkandidatin beackerte
beständig das landkreis große bundesland
während der nachfolger von annegret
kramp karrenbauer mit seinen vielen
bundesweiten auftritten eher distanz
aufbaut zu glatt auf der seite söders in
der korona politik zu widersprüchlich
tobias hans konnte der cdu kein profil
geben für die christdemokraten fängt das
war ja 20 22 schlecht an in kiel will
mit daniel günther schon in sechs wochen
ein ähnlicher politikertyp wiedergewählt
werden die spd spürt heute rückenwind
2017 kam der schulz zog im saarland ins
stottern jetzt sechs monate nach der
bundestagswahl kann sich auch olaf
scholz bestätigt fühlen dazu beigetragen
hat ausgerechnet oskar lafontaine der
immer unvollendete der deutschen politik
hat zuletzt die saar-linke in den
abgrund geführt ihre wähler haben sich
heute neu und das heißt auch zurück zur
spd orientiert anke rehlinger wird nach
drei eher schwierig und gefallen die
vierte sozialdemokratische
ministerpräsidentin vier von acht
trainingserfolg vergrößert nicht nur die
macht der spd im bundesrat er zeigt auch
das größte manko der union anders als
asterix und obelix brauchen cdu und csu
jetzt keinen zaubertrank sondern auf
bundes wie auf landesebene ganz einfach
nur mehr frauen
der kommentar von peter frey und jetzt
gucken wir auf das thema das die welt in
atem hält auch heute hier ist hanna mit
einem ersten überblick in der
bundesregierung wird die möglichkeit
diskutiert einen raketenschutzschild
über deutschland zu installieren
angesichts der bedrohungslage müsse man
sich mit einem solchen abwehrsystem
beschäftigen da sagte die vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses
strack-zimmermann dem sender welt
ähnlich äußerte sich auch der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
union hahn vorbild könnte der
israelische iron dome eisenkuppel sein
widerspruch kommt von teilen der grünen
sie halten das system für deutschland
nicht für tauglich
die diskussion über die registrierung
ukrainischer flüchtlinge geht weiter in
den ministerin feser hat die forderung
der union abgelehnt alle geflüchteten zu
registrieren die menschen hätten das
recht sich hier frei zu bewegen sagte
faeser dem tagesspiegel es gehe vor
allem um kinder und frauen zudem würde
die bundespolizei pässe kontrollieren
der bayerische innenminister herrmann
warnte dagegen in den zeitungen der
mediengruppe vor einer sicherheitslücke
es müsse verhindert werden dass
schleuser oder andere straftäter die
situation ausnutzen
bundespräsident steinmeier hat die
menschen in deutschland wegen des kriegs
in der ukraine auf härtere zeiten
eingestimmt vor einem
solidaritätskonzert im schloss bellevue
rief steinmeier außerdem dazu auf an der
seite der ukraine zu stehen
unsere solidarität und unsere
unterstützung
unsere standhaftigkeit auch unsere
bereitschaft zu einschränkungen
werden noch auf lange zeit gefordert
sein
zu dem konzert der berliner
philharmoniker war auch der ukrainische
botschafter melnik eingeladen er sagte
allerdings ab weil die beiden solisten
die auftraten aus russland stammen
morgen wird die heizsaison in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew vorzeitig
beendet die örtliche militärverwaltung
hat das so angeordnet dann bleiben
wohnungen und geschäftsgebäude kalt kiew
erwartet in den kommenden nächten
temperaturen von ein bis drei grad die
zeichen in der ukraine stehen weiter auf
eskalation russland versuche das land zu
teilen sagt der ukrainische
militärgeheimdienst gleichzeitig kündigt
präsident wolodimir selensky anne die
frage der von russland geforderte
neutralität seines landes gründlich zu
prüfen petra otto fasst die lage heute
zusammen
kinderzimmer im krieg inzwischen fast
schon eingerichtet wie zu hause das ist
es auch für 700 menschen sie wohnen auf
bahnsteigen und in zugabteilen in einer
u bahn station in kharkiv schon seit
ende februar ist nadja da unten mit
ihren beiden kindern aber nicht in
kharkiv auch in kiew ist die metro zur
wohnung geworden
wir gehen nur raus wenn es sein muss um
die kinder zu baden kann schneller oder
um kleider zu waschen her und trocknet
ja nichts
fast täglich bomben auf wohngebiete in
vielen ukrainischen städten bilder von
heute aus kharkiv
in lembeck da löschen sie die halbe
nacht das öl depot das wohl das
ukrainische militär im westteil des
landes versorgen sollte gestern von
russen zerstört erst nach 14 stunden sei
der brand unter kontrolle gewesen
tag für tag zählt der sprecher des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums
kriegs erfolge und zerstörung auf stets
in gleicher manier
und er fügt hinzu die angriffe würden
fortgesetzt nach russischer darstellung
läuft alles nach plan
heute am ehrentag der russischen
nationalgarde größte anerkennung vom
präsidenten für den einsatz in der
ukraine
ich weiß wohl wie sie alle agieren in
dieser situation mit äußerstem mut mit
professionalität geschult resolut
furchtlos und
doch könnte es anzeichen gegeben dass
russland seine haltung möglicherweise
ändert und die sicherung der sogenannten
volksrepublik hans kunden jetzt als
kriegsziel erklärt schwer einschätzbar
warum der separatistenführer von lohans
keine volksabstimmung angekündigt
ich denke dass es in kürzester zeit hier
ein referendum geben wird da können
menschen ihr recht und ihre meinung
kundtun dass sie der russischen
föderation angehören wollen
die ukrainische regierung sie reagiert
prompt gefälschte referenten in den
besetzten teilen der ukraine sind null
und nichtig
die ukraine schützen vor russischen
angriffen museums mitarbeitende packen
cix staaten und monumente in kiew ein
ihre helden und anführer kulturgut
bewahren für die zeit danach wenn ihr
kriegen vorbei ist
wenn man mit einem satz den man so
offenbar gar nicht sagen wollte
plötzlich weltweit auf den titelseiten
der zeitungen ist dann hat man ein
problem beziehungsweise die eigenen
mitarbeiter haben ein problem im weißen
haus hatten sie nämlich alle hände voll
zu tun um diesen einen satz ihres
präsidenten wieder zurückzuholen den er
gestern abend in polen am ende einer
flammenden rede für die freiheit sagte
um gottes willen dieser mann kann nicht
an der macht bleiben nein beeilt sich
das weiße haus sofort klar zu stellen
das sei keine aufforderung zum regime
wechsel zum sturz von wladimir putin
obwohl es genau so klingt markus km ist
sicherheitsexperte bei der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik genannt er
keinen guten abend beiden spricht aus
was viele denken ja aber kann sich ein
us-präsident in diesen zeiten so eine
bemerkung quasi aus der hüfte leisten
sie haben ja selber angedeutet es ist
nicht das erste mal dass präsident biden
sich etwas gehen lässt rhetorisch dinge
sagt die mich abgesprochen waren die
auch nicht im redemanuskript in
beinhaltet gewesen sind er hat seinem
herzen luft verschafft er hat glaube ich
einen in der analyse ein richtigen
befund angegeben dass die ihre russische
präsident in der internationalen
gemeinschaft erst mal ein paar sein wird
geschnitten wird kein
kooperationspartner auf absehbare zeit
sein wird aber er hätte es besser nicht
gesagt weil es lenkt von den wirklichen
prioritäten ab der amerikanischen
politik nämlich jetzt erstmal in die
ukraine damals zu unterstützen den krieg
zu führen diesen krieg einer politischen
lösung durch zuzuführen und dazu gehört
dann eben auch gespräche mit russland in
der ein oder anderen form zu führen
bevor wir auf die gespräche mit russland
die dann möglicherweise nötig sind noch
zu sprechen kommen erstmal die frage ist
das was beiden da gesagt hat am ende
sogar ein geschenk möglicherweise für
putin also sagen wir so es hat zwei
nachteile die erste ist es was auch ihre
mühlen der russischen propaganda die er
seit wochen und monaten immer wieder
betont dass überwölbende westliche ziel
wäre eine lean back sind in russland
dass caesar russland zu teilen zu
spalten zur demütigung und anderes mehr
das ist meines erachtens nicht der fall
aber man leistet damit einen dieser
dieser propaganda weiter vorschub und
ist zwar habe ich gerade fertig
angedeutet in der in der ein oder
anderen form mit russland für ein
kompromiss gebraucht und damit mit einem
solchen statement erhöht mir nicht
kompromissfähig kite und
kompromissbereit auf der russischen
seite sondern verschärft er die fronten
und das ist zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
nicht produktiv wenn das jetzt ein
moralischer aufruf quasi des us
präsidenten war da muss ja wladimir
putin endgültig klar sein dass er enden
kann wie es saddam hussein am ende
ergangen ist wo ist denn da dann noch
raum für diplomatie oder gab es den
sowieso schon nicht mehr auch vor der
beiden rede also ich glaube zumindest im
moment gibt es wenig raum für diplomatie
es gibt noch gespräche zwischen dem
französischen präsidenten und
bundeskanzler scholz und dem russischen
präsidenten aber selbst die berichten ja
dass es auf russischer seite keine
bewegung maetzig gibt in den
verhandlungspositionen auch die direkten
gespräche zwischen russland und der
ukraine die seit wochen andauern führen
immer wenn zunächst so dass sich der
eindruck aufdrängt die russische seite
für das taktischen gründen verhandlung
ohne substanzielle haben interessiert zu
sein also diplomat bewegt sich im moment
wenig das kann sich im verlauf des
krieges allerdings wieder schnell ändern
und das haben wir versucht anzudeuten
dann wird ausland gebraucht und dafür es
ist wenig hilfreich russland in einer
ecke zu stellen weil losgelöst von der
frage was der amerikanische präsident
vom russischen präsidenten halten mag
russland ist kriegspartei und wenn wir
darüber nachdenken wie dieser krieg
hinein vom militärischen noch politisch
zu ende zu bringen ist dafür mit
russland gebraucht
markus kaim von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik herr kaim
herzlichen dank sehr gerne
und weitere wichtige nachrichten heute
an diesem sonntag nochmal hanna es ist
ein historisches gipfeltreffen in israel
sind am abend us-außenminister blinken
und sein amtskollege la pete mit
repräsentanten der vereinigten
arabischen emirate bryans marokkos und
des sudans zusammengekommen im
sogenannten nägel im süden israels soll
es um den ukraine krieg gehen aber auch
um den iran und israel konflikt mit den
palästinensern
erst seit 2020 hat israel nach und nach
diplomatische beziehungen mit den vier
arabischen staaten aufgenommen sie
bilden eine allianz gegen iran
wegen steigender corona zahlen geht die
chinesische wirtschaftsmetropole
shanghai ab morgen in einen strikten
lockdown die hafenstadt zählte zuletzt
mehr als 2600 neuinfektionen zuerst wird
im östlichen teil shanghais eine
ausgangssperre verhängt ab freitag dann
im westlichen teil zudem wurden
massentests angeordnet der betrieb von
bussen bahnen fairen und taxis wird
eingestellt und es gilt eine home office
pflicht ausgenommen ist die
lebensmittelversorgung der
skispringer severin freund hat heute
beim weltcup finale in planica
überraschend sein karriereende
bekanntgegeben
freund ist der erfolgreichste deutsche
skispringer der vergangenen 20 jahre
jeden team gold bei olympia verbucht er
vier wm titel und einen sieg im
gesamtweltcup
sein teamkollege karl geiger kam in
planica nur auf rang 16 und hat damit
den ohnehin kaum noch möglichen triumph
im gesamt weltcup verpasst wo der
gesamtzweiter hinter dem japaner
kobayashi
ich bin pessimist für die gegenwart aber
optimist für die zukunft hat wilhelm
busch gesagt hier ist das was uns
bevorsteht die kommende woche im
heute-journal ausblick von laura panik
[Musik]
am montag werden die europäischen
innenminister in brüssel über die
aufnahme der ukraine flüchtlinge beraten
die eu will die verteilung der
flüchtlinge besser koordinieren zudem
werden die wiedereinführung von
grenzkontrollen und fragen zur inneren
sicherheit diskutiert
ein diplomatisch hat drahtseilakt dürfte
der freitag werden wie schon
2021 findet ein virtuelles treffen
zwischen der eu und china statt in der
eu werden stimmen lauter china wegen
seiner unterstützung russlands mit
harten wirtschaftssanktionen zu bewegen
gleichzeitig will man mit china aber
handel betreiben
bundesweit laufen am samstag die
maßnahmen gegen korona aus unter anderem
wird es ab dem 2 april keine allgemeine
masten pflicht oder kontakt
beschränkungen für ungeimpfte geben in
den sogenannten hotspots können aber
weiterhin bei sehr hohen inzidenz
maßnahmen verlängert oder wieder
eingeführt werden
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten
morgen im norden teils dichte wolken
aber nur vereinzelt regen sonst viel
sonne im bergland aber auch einige
quellwolken 9 bis 17 grad im norden bis
22 grad im süden die weiteren aussichten
am dienstag in der mitte etwas regen im
süden noch einmal freundlich und mild
danach wechselhaft und deutliche
abkühlung am donnerstag nur noch vier
bis zwölf grad
tausende menschen harren nach wie vor
aus in den u bahn röhren von katies der
zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine die seit
wochen von der russischen armee
bombardiert wird eigentlich sollte dort
jetzt das archiv musikfest starten mit
gästen aus der ganzen welt das festival
fällt aus aber der lärm des krieges kann
die musik nicht stoppen sagen die
organisatoren
licht triumphiert über die dunkelheit
das sind nur worte aber sie sind nicht
leer
die die hier aufgetreten sind unter der
erde die dröhnt vom einschlag der
raketen sagten mit tränen in den augen
es war wohl das beste konzert unseres
lebens
und das war unsere welt an diesem
sonntag im heute journal morgen begrüßen
wie hier marietta slomka und heinz wolf
einen guten abend
[Musik]